hey guys Pete here it's been awhile but
there has been some new game of thrones
new so this will be my weekly spoilers
report if you don't like that production
spoilers or news about what the cast is
doing and what's going to happen in
season seven then you're going to want
to stop watching now with out of the way
let's jump right into it earlier this
week we got some photos from Iceland and
initially it was just crew members who
were there we actually got quite a few
photos of them which a reddit username
JD hardstark compiled together on the
free folk subreddit most of the crew you
wouldn't know but these guys are
supposedly related to costumes which
means that it's not likely that they're
there just to shoot scenery for the
backgrounds and things like that
we also found out that they were going
to be there for a few weeks which means
that we expected to see at least some
shooting with the cast for scenes that
were beyond the wall now this isn't to
be confused with the rumors that we had
earlier that there was a location that
was in my other videos where we had like
a sort of ditch or a dolly something
like that you know like a corridor in
the ice
this is a totally different location and
if you remember back to season two and
three
I mean when they were beyond the wall
those were great locations and that is
sort of what we're looking at here in
these photos from Instagram sure enough Kit Harrington was spotted there in the
next day or so so we knew that this was
probably related to the story that we've
been following at the wolf Phil Koury
seen not really sure how it tied
together like will they be ranging
around looking for this bite this lets
me bring back to King's Landing or is it
all going to be tied together in some
other way on top of jon snow we got
Thoreau's and Joe Dempsie who plays
injuries that showed up which also ties
into the whole expedition to capture the
white but like i said it's not clear
whether part of this is background to
lead up to that scene they've been
shooting on the frozen lake that they
set up in Northern Ireland
and we're just going to have to wait and
see knowing what we know about the
directors and where people have been up
into this point though it's definitely
clear that they're not going to be
beyond the wall for a very long period
of time so one of the other these two
will be tied together and it will all
lead up to what we talked about is most
likely going to be the epic battle scene
of the season which will happen in you
know because this is the shorter season
of seven episodes that will happen in
episode 6 so it's not a lot of set news
or spoilers like we're used to but we
gotta take what we can get at this point
the on-ice when I don't know that
they're going to be filming anywhere
else outdoors so things are going to get
a lot quieter but I'll be keeping my
eyes peeled for any news that comes
around and non show related news we did
get one interesting tidbit that was
reported on a whole lot but it didn't
really say that much on his personal
blog george RR martin said that he
thinks winds of winter will be out in
it was a response to a comment where
someone told him that he ought to give
us all a break basically and give us an
update and his exact words are you
really think statements like that would
make a difference
are you sweet summer child i have years
of experience with this that tells me
otherwise
but ok I'll try it your way not done yet
but I've made progress but not as much
as I hope the year ago when I thought
I'd be done by now I think it will be
out this year but hey I thought the same
thing last year and it was sounded
really great up to that last little bit
because we know this takes time and with
most of us thinking that it was going to
be coming out this spring that's pretty
much off the table according to what he
said just now but I mean it is a glimmer
of hope we can hope to get it around the
same time season 7 comes out or you know
right after but I'm not holding my
breath that we're going to get it and
read it before we actually start
watching the next season in case you
haven't been following he did do an
interview where he talked about how it's
going to be really dark and that's not a
big surprise to all of us who've been
waiting for this book
winter is the time of death and dying
that's what he basically saying is going
to be going on
not necessarily in the character sense
but just that it's going to be a tough
time for everyone
one more show related that we got it was
really just a confirmation though it had
been reported that tom hopper was going
to be playing Dick entirely and we found
out for sure that's the case Freddie
stroma who played him in the liars
season told IGN that he would be not
able to carry on with the show because
of other commitments this isn't a big
surprise to us but like I said it is a
confirmation so regrettably that's going
to be it for this installation not any
other real news to report on Game of
Thrones was nominated for various awards
nothing really the point out I guess I'm
still a little bit jaded over the whole
golden globe thing they didn't win any
and tangent Newton didn't win for
westworld so the award type is a little
bit low on my priority of things right
now as far as my channel is concerned
I've been taking a break just because of
the poor time of the year for YouTube
got a bunch of different stuff i'm
planning to put it out over the next
couple weeks now that everything's back
in swing
I didn't want to have a bunch of videos
come out that would not get watched
because after doing a little bit of
research i found out that the first two
weeks of January are the worst weeks for
views and for added income so it just
seemed like a good time to head to
Thailand so that's where i've been at
and I guess that I'll probably do some
more the spoiler recap but I wanted to
wait and see what we find out about ice
land which I'm talking about today
because that's going to be like one of
the last you know big things that we
have as far as filming goes so please
like the video if you enjoyed it make
sure you leave a comment if you have any
questions or any theories about what's
going on north of the wall the book
giveaway is still going on and all you
have to do is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on this video or any of the
other ones that i mentioned this
giveaway in when i reached 20,000
subscribers i will give away the 20th
anniversary edition of a game of thrones
by george RR
Martin thanks for watching I'll talk to
you soon